here's a question about school choice in
a state like Arizona as well and this is
replicated throughout the country if
property values are based on perceived
school values which are based on tax
rates and whatnot and they're all I mean
people don't want to risk a major change
in the school system if it's going to
disrupt their property values right
right so is that an issue and if so how
do you work around a balut Lee an issue
you have a lot of people look school
choices as this bhayo likes to say
school choices widespread unless you're
poor alright so those of us with the
funds to do so have carefully selected
homes in high quality districts and and
those of us who have done these things I
include myself in this category not then
to turn around and say oh well I've got
mine it sucks to be you however that is
a reality and there are people to do
that the point is is that parental
choice does not threaten these people
because actually what it'll do is make
they're already paid for choice to their
schools more effective as well right so
there's a lot of complacency in sort of
you know the leafy suburbs but the fact
is is they're not competitive either
right even even upper middle-class white
America are not achieving it a level
anything like you know say the top
European and Asian system so you know
the Pacific research not issue but an
excellent book called not as good as
they think right where people are paying
you know it was featured and waiting for
superman the movie people are paying a
million-dollar mortgages and sending
their kids to underperforming public
schools it's actually much more common
than people think